je peux prendre assez large et à la
place séance de conduite pour larbi au
volant de son chariot élévateur cet
ouvrier cariste est venu ici pour se
remettre à niveau en parler les choses
les exercices si on prend des choses que
nous manque c'est compliqué non c'est
pas compliqué notamment comment savoir
si le premier exercice comme lui une
dizaine de stagiaires s'entraînent à
manoeuvrer ces engins de levage un
savoir-faire très demandés par le tissu
industriel du nord franche comté c'est
des engins qui sont beaucoup utilisés
dans l'industrie l'on travaille beaucoup
dans l'industrie avec psa qui est pas
loin et cetera
donc c'est des engins qu'on va beaucoup
utilisé même dans les plus petites
structures aussi la réforme de la
formation professionnelle lancée l'an
dernier dope le secteur dont ce centre
installé entre montbéliard et héricourt
de nouvelles formations plus longues et
plus complètes sont en train de voir le
jour
elle allie conduite d'engins manutention
et logistique et dure 45 jours cette
déformation qui sont recherchées puisque
dans le cadre du plan d'investissement
dans les compétences une enveloppe e a
été allouée justement donc pour ces
formations longues donc pour l'emploi
normalement et susceptibles d'être
intéressées d'ailleurs on a déjà
développé quatre formations qui ont été
financés par le pôle emploi de bure et
lahoud sont pour l'instant là où je ne
suis bien des formations destinées en
priorité aux chômeurs de longue durée ou
aux salariés en reconversion avec à la
clé une forte probabilité de trouver
rapidement un emploi dans la région